hello everyone I'm Neil Patterson and
welcome to the Sky News Daily today
let's talk about suela Braverman because
guess what she's in trouble once again
I jest of course because the more
eagle-eyed of you will have noticed that
the Home Secretary is never too far away
from a headline on the front pages you
might remember her thwarted leadership
ambition she got to the second round of
the conservative leadership contest and
then decided to help out Rishi sunak
you'll be very well aware of her plans
to send people to Rwanda and of course
her strategy to stop the boats but no
she finds herself in hot water over a
speeding fight if you ask civil serpents
to put you on a one-on-one speed
increase in relation to the process I'm
focused on delivering for the British
people do my job safely and what I will
say is that in my view I'm confident
that nothing untoward has happened
now what we know and facts are still
emerging is that way back in 2022 when
she was the Attorney General she was
caught speeding as often is the case she
was offered the chance to avoid three
points on her license by participating
in one of those speed awareness courses
but the story has then developed a
couple of complications first that she
asked our civil servants to intervene in
the matter second that her advisor May
well have misled reporters who were
chasing the very story little surprise
then that journalists are now in
something of a high-speed pursuit of the
truth and guess what we're taking you
along for the right
[Music]
okay but let us start with the fact as
we understand them our political
correspondent Rob Powell well he has
just hightailed it back from Downing
Street Rob I mean first things first
what exactly has swella bravaman been
accused of I think there's a couple of
key issues to this Neil I think the
first is basically the sort of bad
optics for politicians
um of asking for something that isn't
generally available to The Wider public
in this case it's that Sue Ella bravnum
was caught speeding last summer and like
anyone she was given the option of
either taking the points on her license
or doing a speed awareness course
initially she chose to do the speed
awareness course then when she became
Home Secretary she attempted to get
civil servants and then a political
advisor to see if they could arrange a
private one-to-one speed awareness cause
instead of going to a group session when
that was knocked back and rebutted by
the speed awareness people she then
decided just to take the point so I
think the first thing is that she is
essentially asking for something that
looks like she didn't want to be
publicly identified as the Home
Secretary who'd been speeding and caught
out the second thing which I think is
maybe the more substantive issue around
the ministerial code where she could get
into more bother if there's to be an
inquiry is that she initially asked
civil servants to help her with this now
civil servants are the politically
impartial bits of government and to ask
them to sort of be getting involved in
your personal affairs potentially
contravenes part of the ministerial code
around maintaining Civil Service
impartiality so I think those are the
the two things for Sue Ella bravman that
she's having to battle with at the
moment yeah I mean Dave Penman from the
FDA Union that Union that represents
many many civil servants I mean said
this they don't do their shopping they
don't look after their children and they
don't sort out their parking fines I
mean there has to be a barrier a
delineation between the work that is
expected of civil servants be their
political appointees like special
advisors or career civil service and the
minister that they're working for yeah
well whatsoeverman's team say is this
wasn't so much sort of using the Civil
Service as sort of extended housekeeping
this was more her checking over what she
should be doing because she initially
got this speed awareness course in this
fine this penalty when she was Attorney
General then she was appointed Home
Secretary which comes with a big step up
in terms of the security protection and
the security regime that you have to
have along with that post they
maintained that this was about her
checking what would happen now if she
had to go to a speed awareness course
who she would have to take with her the
other thing to say is well on Sunday we
spoke to one high-profile lawyer
nicknamed Mr loophole
famed for getting people like off um
road traffic penalties and incidents and
things like that and he said look
there's nothing unusual about
high-profile people doing one-to-ones
and actually often the speed awareness
people quite like it because all of the
other people sat in there being told off
for speeding um don't get distracted by
the fact that the Home Secretary sat in
the corner with three blokes with you
know guns shut down their trousers so on
that I mean I'm not necessarily sure
that either of these things are a sort
of mortal fatal blow to swella Braven
and I think even if she's found to have
broken the ministerial code over
involving civil servants that's not
necessarily at the most egregious end of
breaches that you can go through on I
think the difficulty for her though is
this is something else to add into the
kind of crowded fraught political
landscape that she's trying to navigate
at the moment it is more noise and more
fuss that Rishi sunax Home Secretary is
causing and it's whether he feels or
whether she feels that they want to
carry on in this position in this
situation where more things seem to be
added on top of the the various
challenges she's having to deal with in
terms of her Candor on this topic we
have the daily matter suggesting that
when her special advisor was directly
asked you know has she been Court
speeding the answer came back no
bold-faced lie so this is another part
of this story which could eventually
land her in a bit of trouble as well as
you say this was six weeks or so ago a
mirror reporter went to her team and
asked them about whether she'd been on a
speed awareness course they said no now
interestingly last night when the mirror
published this story the special advisor
in question I messaged and asked whether
that story in the mirror was true
whether they'd essentially lied to a
newspaper about it and I got a reply
back saying it's not true that I was
asked about driver awareness courses and
I denied that that is true and that is
accurate because she didn't go on the
speed awareness course she took the
penalty but then on this question of
whether she had had a speeding penalty
the explanation I got back from this
official in question on that was that
they couldn't recall and had no
recollection of that part of the
conversation now of course the mirror
then subsequently published the entire
transcript of it which made clear that
he was this person was asked about this
when I went back to the advisor in
question about that they essentially
said that it was a long conversation
they couldn't recall the details of it
but that does pose difficulties firstly
because it suggests that a member of her
advisory team have been misleading
journalists secondly though the more
interesting question which I haven't
been able to get to the bottom of with
the official in question is whether at
the time he was telling the truth
whether he knew at the time whether this
speeding penalty had happened and
essentially whether the Home Secretary
had held back that information and I
think if there is mileage and potential
for that that Home Secretary could get
an even hotter water if it essentially
emerges that she'd been misleading
people about the existence of the
speeding fine and speeding penalty in
the first place
curiouser and curiouser but look absent
a screeching handbrake turn and tone
from the Home Secretary I mean the key
question is whether what happened
amounts to a breach of what's known as
the ministerial could and if so what
punishment is then Justified let's bring
in Tim Durant from The Institute for
government Tim a couple of definitions
to start us off exactly what is the
ministerial code and what is it supposed
to achieve so the ministerial code is a
document that each prime minister issues
when they first come into office setting
out what they expect of their ministers
what ministers are able to do how they
can use government resources what
they're expected to declare in terms of
their personal interests and basically
how they behave in government it doesn't
have a legal status it's kind of status
and its power comes from the fact that
the Prime Minister says this is what I
expect of my ministers and I will make
sure that you are helped to account in
this way of behaving so on the face of
it with the level of knowledge that we
all possess about what seems to have
been going on with Sorella Braverman and
points and driving courses and and the
rest of it does it appear to you that
the code has been breached I mean uh I'm
not going to give you a straight answer
I'm afraid I think I thought you might
not I think
what it depends on is exactly what she
asked of her civil servant so if she
asked
this has happened I've been caught
speeding are you able to help me work
out a way to get a private feeding
awareness course that's one thing right
they can say no Minister we're not
allowed to do that because that's a
personal issue and we can't help you
with that and that's totally fine you
know she's able to ask for guidance and
say you know can you explain to me
exactly the the level of support that
you as civil servants can provide for me
that's okay if she says I want you to
find this and I want you to make this
special arrangement for me that is I
think more problematic because that
suggests that she either didn't
understand or wasn't taking into account
the fact that the Civil Service aren't
supposed to provide that kind of support
for ministers but at the end of the day
the Civil Service quite rightly said I'm
sorry to Home Secretary we cannot do
that for you we work for for the
government we are not able to support
you in this personal issue that you're
dealing with so actually I think it
depends very much on the kind of the
tenor of the request that was made I
think another question that he's looking
into is what exactly she told her
special advisors to say and I think
that's potentially more interesting
right so why more problematic because
she is the kind of boss of that special
advisor she's the manager and there is a
requirement on special advisors to be
honest and there is a requirement on
ministers to be honest and if there is a
kind of explicit attempt to kind of hide
this information that I think does raise
questions about whether or not
potentially the special advisor code or
the ministerial code was breached but
with all of these potential breaches
what is ultimately going to come down to
is the prime minister's judgment just on
that topic because as you've already
mentioned the ministerial code is is not
a legally binding document same I
presume would be the case for the spad
code as well so everything ultimately
then is as you say comes down to the
Judgment of one individual the Prime
Minister presumably with with some input
from his ethics advisor absolutely so so
Lori Magnus is is the PM's advisor or
ministerial interests and if the PM asks
him to undertake an investigation he can
talk to the Home Secretary he can talk
to her team and say okay what was the
nature of the conversations that were
had can you explain who asked what and
what happened he would then write that
up into a report which he delivered to
Rishi sunak but it is British unak's
decision yeah you're sorry sorry to
interrupt let's be just be absolutely
clear here this investigation does not
start Solari does not begin any four of
work unless Rishi sunak goes I'd like
you to look into this it is his decision
the decision is entirely and solely
within his purview absolutely so Solari
could say prime minister I think I
should look into this and
the expectation I think would be that
the Prime Minister would say yes but as
you say it's his decision he could say
no we have had prime ministers ignore
their ethics advisor haven't we
absolutely Boris Johnson ignored the
findings of one of his advisors who then
resigned so the investigation may or may
not even happen but if it does happen at
the end of it so Laurie Magnus will
write this report and deliver it to the
Prime Minister and again it is the prime
minister's decision okay based on what
you have told me I think this is or is
not a breach of the ministerial code and
if it is then this is the the kind of
sanction or sort of outcome that I I
want in this case so it all comes down
to the PM and kind of his relationship
with the Home Secretary the kind of
political considerations that he will be
making okay there is no kind of if x
then y has written into the code
I suspect I'm about to ask another
question to it she won't be desperate to
provide an immediate and feel some
answer but I'm going to try anyway I
mean what is the point of having an
independent ethics advisor if that
independent ethics advisor cannot act
independently that they cannot start an
investigation without the literal
written sign off of the Prime Minister I
mean do we have a functional system of
Ethics within government I mean it's a
question that we Institute have asked as
well you know we we've argued that
Solari and and that the person in that
role should have the ability to start
their own investigations without the
permission of the Prime Minister because
as you say that's the only way that they
are fully independent so at the moment
so Laurie is clearly sort of
independently minded and the prime
minister
when there have been allegations in the
past about ministerial misbehavior the
Prime Minister has always said okay I
would like an investigation so at the
moment I think you can argue that the
system as it is constructed is working
well the problem with the current system
and this kind of informality of it and
the fact that it all relies on the prime
minister is if there is a prime minister
who is less fast about integrity and
ethical behavior in government either
they can not request an investigation be
started or they could not appoint a
ministerial advisor in in the first
place so Liz truss she was only prime
minister for a few weeks but she didn't
appoint a ministerial advisor uh during
her her Premiership
and so I think this this speaks to the
point that you know if a prime minister
decides that this issue is not important
to them or is willing to just kind of
ride out the criticism there's no way of
kind of enforcing those ethical or
standards in government if the PM isn't
involved so I think yeah you know down
the line a stronger role for the
independent advisor where they are able
to start their own investigations
without requiring the PM's permission
and indeed publish the findings of those
investigations because as well we won't
find out what Solari has said to the
Prime Minister until Downing Street
decides that it can be made public
see here's here's the thing Tim I'm I'm
old enough and ugly enough to remember a
time when you know we never even got
this far into the process that cabinet
ministers who'd been caught with their
trousers down would just resign they
would hand the letter into number 10
leave cabinet spend a year in the
wilderness and then come back to another
cabinet job you know 12 18 months later
I mean have you ever known a political
period like this Dominic RAV
investigation as well a Braverman thing
that's going on partygate and so on
ministers hanging around in positions
that they were clearly not suited for
and frankly in a previous age would have
resigned from the post in disgrace I
think as you say there's been a sort of
a snowball of these kind of stories over
the last few years I think the specific
issue here with Zoella brotherman's
speeding ticket
I think actually if that were just
happening in isolation maybe this
wouldn't be such a big you know
discussion but it's because of that
context it's because of Sue Ella
Brockman resigned from let's Justice
government because she was found to have
broken the ministerial code last year
and then was reappointed by Rishi sunak
a week later she's also the Home
Secretary and she was attorney general
when when the speeding happened so these
are two roles that are all about kind of
Law and Order and upholding upholding
the law and so you know that kind of
raises questions about okay well do we
expect particularly high standards of
people in those roles compared to to
anyone in public life so I think you
need to look at both the issue of of
what's been alleged and again we don't
know the full details yet there hasn't
been a full investigation but it's also
bearing in mind that wider context which
I think perhaps has changed our
expectations and meant that people kind
of reach for the ministerial code or
reach for a kind of ethical allegation
in a way that perhaps if if this was
happening in 2018 people would have you
know asked a couple of questions but we
would have moved on
thank you
now I know this because I've done it
myself whenever a cabinet minister ends
up on the front pages we journalists
have a favorite game standing in dining
streets outside number 10 shouting at
them any regrets Home Secretary
are you subject to different laws than
the rest of us I'm secretary
is it time to go but I have to admit I
am far more interested in a more
official response from the government
let's bring Rob Poe our political
correspondent back in Rob what have we
been hearing from the government yeah so
where we are right now is that Richard
sunlight the Prime Minister spoke to his
ethics advisor this morning consulted
with him yeah so this is on Mishi sunak
whether he wants to get Solari Magnus to
investigate at the moment at 10 to 2 in
the afternoon we don't have that
information number 10 aren't able to
confirm that yet but clearly that comes
with a big political judgment in that if
he does decide to take some sort of
action against sweller Braven he risks a
degree of tension or a bit of a spat if
you like with some of her supporters on
the sort of more pro-brexit right-wing
side of the party yeah I mean look this
is this is certainly not happening at a
politically opportune moment for for
either the prime minister or indeed the
Home Secretary a little later this week
we've got those immigration figures
coming out and and frankly we're all
sitting here expecting it to be an
eye-watering number yeah and I think
this is all massively relevant to what
is going on with the Home Secretary at
the moment there's the migration
statistics as you say which are expected
later this week that will show levels we
think going to another record high now
when you're a Home Secretary like suela
bravman who Styles themselves as a bit
of a hardliner on this this is not
something that you want to wear the
other part that's going been going on
below the water line is something of a
push and pull within government within
cabinet on how to get those numbers down
so swella Brockman has a degree of
government level tension going on there
is also a degree of party level tension
around her as well which I think really
started to grow from a speech she gave a
week ago at the national conservatism
conference a right-wing conference not
tied to government and I was sat in that
speech listening to it and quite frankly
it sounded more like a speech that
someone in a Tory leadership campaign
would give rather than a sitting
government Minister there was sort of a
lot about her backstory and her family
history what she sees conservatism as
there were sort of calls for the UK to
train their more of their own fruit
Pickers and butchers there wasn't a lot
on government policy it almost sounded
like this was someone campaigning from
the outside to influence immigration
policy rather than the person that
basically has their finger on the button
and has the control over it in the first
place now as the week's gone on I'm told
that has robbed various Tory MPS up the
wrong way so whilst it appeals to one
section others frankly felt she went too
far she overstepped where the government
line was and she did something that
sounded too much like a leadership pitch
and I think when you take that sort of
government-led tension and the party LED
tension together it breeds this sort of
swamp whereby leaks and embarrassing
stories like the speeding fine more
easily pop out but when swella bravaman
is addressing that right-wing National
conservatism conference the NAT Seas as
I saw some Wags describing it on social
media over the past few days I mean she
has in essence speaking to her base
within the party isn't she so I am just
wondering if someone is licking this
stuff
do they really want her on the back
benches because presumably that is where
she is most dangerous if she's in
cabinet then at least the Prime Minister
has a leash on her yeah I mean there's
various theories about how the story
over the weekend made it into the into
the public domain none of which I I know
to be true I don't know which one is
correct but I can share the various
theories if you like the one is that it
was a sanctioned warning shot from
government to try and basically put her
back in a box after that speech last
Monday the difficulty clearly with that
is you don't want to necessarily end up
in a position where you're riling up the
right of the party and causing the Prime
Minister more damage I think maybe the
most likely explanation for it is it's
someone that could think they're doing
number 10 a favor so whilst it's not
sanctioned by government it's someone
who is an ally of the Prime Minister who
thinks they're doing a favor to number
10 by essentially trying to kind of clip
the wings of someone who has been
causing problems but as you say it
presents an opportunity essentially that
if sweater Brahman feels like she
doesn't want to wear the migration data
she doesn't want to wear being a Home
Secretary essentially overseeing a very
liberal immigration policy at the moment
something that could curtail future
leadership hopes if she hopes to sort of
get into number 10 on the back of the
right of the party this gives her a way
out which is why if it is someone doing
it to try and benefit Rishi sunak it
actually could end up wounding him of
course you try to read into where
stories come from and the reality of it
is sometimes it's a bit of everything
and it's someone that maybe gets a
little bit carried away in a bar or
chatting with a journalist so it may not
be a sort of set conspiracy like this
but I think the fact that there are
various explanations that pop up around
it show that at the moment Sue Ella
Braven is she is playing various levels
of political games with various other
opponents and people within her party
and I think it won't necessarily work
out well for her and it may not work out
well for the Prime Minister either
my thanks to Rob Powell Tim Durant and
of course to you for listening to the
Sky News Daily with me Neil Patterson
this episode was produced by Rosie
Gillett our editor is Philly bunt
[Music]